you know that that's where it was
life-changing for me I think Snoop so
much for for hand selecting that that
lineup because you did hand select that
lineup and I feel super grateful for
that I got a chance to bond with some of
my you know mentors and some of my the
guys I grew up listening to and looking
up to got a chance to chill with the
Taylor gang you know that's family
me and Stu got some deals coming out
that that tour that are pretty big we
got cookies by cookies coming soon under
his food umbrella so we're ready please
buy cookies yeah just snacks good snacks
I like that not infused Walmart baby
yo for Snoop like I feel like have you
because because when we think of
weed and Hip-Hop we think I think it's
Snoop and then I think it wins and I
think it'd be real then I think of you
but in terms of just like the general
public everyone thinks of Snoop Dogg
right you've done some weed stuff with
Snoop um for whatever reason it feels
like Snoop hasn't fully
um cracked off in the space
in a way that you would expect him to I
know you guys have done stuff
um but have you have you like helped
Snoop out at all in that in that space
we launched we launched something
together that did hella well uh the
doggy bag it killed it I mean when we
dropped it and in La the lines were down
the block we dropped in other markets
people loved it was a good genetic but I
think the thing was Snoop is that he's
way bigger than just focusing on a weed
brand he's he's an international [__]
icon no it's crazy this guy this guy I'm
I always tell this to people he's the
most famous rapper in the world I think
he's like he's one of the most famous
people he's like the closest like and I
say this this may be a weird statement
he's like the closest guy to Michael
Jackson out there like he's no one like
Michael everyone knows who Snoop Dogg
everybody I don't care where you go your
grand like you know who the dog is you
know who the dog is so I think that the
dog I think that soup plus weed he's a
fan of weed he loves to smoke good weed
I've gotten high with them for years
he's done multiple Brands but I think
that he's just so much bigger than
trying to focus on the weed brain he's
focused on like the food category now
with the ice cream and the cereal like I
think he's focused on just like bigger
plays that he didn't really think he'd
be able to do you know when he was
younger Snoop and I think they're like
the Walmart yeah [__] like that yeah I
mean he's not only getting into Walmart
he's opening the doors for other people
like he didn't have to open that door
for me that's why I bought him the Rolex
at the last day of the tour because I
was like
you know I don't even know if they'll
ever wear this watch but like I'm so
grateful that
he opened up the door for me to help
normalize my myself as a household name
and by introducing that partner to
develop create cookies and to and to
actually distribute into places like
Walmart that's big as [__] for me and
I'm grateful for that and I think that I
told him that day I said you're the only
artist I know that gives back like this
yeah you share your platform back yeah
you don't want nothing back he told me
burn up simple you could have brought me
a little bag we could say I know I could
have but like I want to give you this
from the heart because this is what you
know in my world like this is I've
always dreamed about being able to do
something like this and like this tour
brought a lot of Happiness to my life in
a really dark time and this tour gave me
motivation to keep making music and it
showed me that around the country I'm
respected all in different markets I
never thought I would be and [__] bro
like you're opening up big doors for us
so shout out to Snoop he's the only guy
that actually really shares his platform
and gives back and gives opportunities
to other artists when he ain't got to do
that [__] at all that's that's my role
model really no soup I I always see him
popping up on up and coming artist [__]
too like
just like just randomly you'll be like
damn snoop's on like a zo Osama remix or
he's on a Scarlet record like and it's
just like oh he's he's not only is he
like you know he's just tapped in and I
feel like he's he's generous with his
energy man
that dude ain't gotta do that dude's
Caked Up for sure the Snoop Dogg is
Caked Up liquidly Caked Up in like his
money's not in equity he wanted he's
Caked Up For Real for reals and he don't
have to do nothing she's doing he's
doing because he loves it and that's the
dope thing about the dog have any of the
like you know like when we think of a
guy like Diddy or we think of a guy like
hope have you had any discussions with
those guys at all about maybe just kind
of gaming them up in terms of the space
because it is a space that
you know like you said it helps to be
somebody who came from that life you
know what I mean someone who's a smoker
someone who cares about the culture of
cannabis yeah I mean I've sat down with
Diddy I had like really really cool like
sit down with him and had a good
relationship with him personally
dude's a [__] Legend bro he's an
iconic dude for sure I've actually had
the opportunity to talk with Jay-Z as
well
and you know it was a very it's like a
30 minute call but it was life goal [__]
yeah was that just about just like
cannabis and like where cannabis is
going and he gave me a lot of game
um
you know we just were sharing your
thoughts about things and that's kind of
told them that you know like my goal
with this business is to leave it to my
daughter
but I would like to find a way to exit
one day and get some liquidity actually
get some real cash a couple hundred
million bucks that'd be cool yeah he
gave me some real game on how to do that
I'm grateful for that I gave him some
game we talked about doing something you
just never really moved like that but
like I was on the [__] Zuma Jay-Z it
was pretty cool it's crazy you know what
I mean like it's pretty [__] cool you
know talk to the whole salute to him
I'm grateful for the game you gave me I
hope that he found the game I gave him
valuable I'm here if they ever want to
chop it up again you know like game
Diddy some good game he gave me some
good game you know so I feel blessed
like it's one thing to be on that list
um I even sat down with Dr Dre about
weed before really yeah like face to
face yeah what was this face-to-face
dream meeting like crazy because that's
really for someone who grew up in that
uh I told you I would give you gems on
this I [__] with you you're very
consistent with like caring about my
story but like yeah shout out to slim
the mobster man
um he made a call back in the days yo
slim the mobster
[__] he was on aftermath he was in jail
and he made a call and from jail was on
the phone and you know I went and went
to go sit down with Drake I was like nah
man he ain't here man he ain't here that
was like shooting me away I was like man
slim I'm here bro
he ain't trying he said hold on
boom boom boom and not get let in I go
sit down and uh Andrea sat down with me
and I and I showed him a jar of what we
wanted to call The Chronic and it was by
far the best looking weed we've ever
produced
it was incredible beautiful it was
orange purple funky stanky just buzz
looked it was like it would look like it
was out of a [__] movie how good this
weed looked I showed him the chronic and
he was just like yeah
I [__] with it and I appreciate slim
putting this play together and you know
we'll think about it but like
I don't know if I really want to kind of
put myself in the industry and I I got
you know he told me I got money money
and I don't really want to play with
that until you know maybe it's federally
illegal I just don't want to risk it I'm
like what year was this this was like
like three or four years ago oh [__] so
not too far not too long ago yeah
um and I said I respect that and I said
can I leave this with you for yourself
or those who smoke he's like for sure
and I got like a nervous picture with
him uh Frederick took the picture for me
because he was air shot to Frederick
uh but yeah I think it's cool that like
being on that hip-hop list I think it's
cool because like Dre saw me he had to
see you and be like oh that's I remember
that guy yeah I remember that guy he
pitched me on this week because he's
doing pretty well yeah I guess it
[__] worked for him I think it's cool
because I got a chance to share moments
with Diddy and I got a chance to share
moments with Jay-Z and those are the top
four yeah and I didn't get I've never
met Kanye you know I don't know whatever
I have no opinion on that but I'm just
saying it's cool because I've ran into
all those guys and I felt good for them
to see me up there because I told them
what I wanted to do and what I was
building at the time and now they see
they have to see the list oh [__]
because the same guy that does their
evaluation and is kind of making sure
that you know they're they're their net
worth is credible and relevant is doing
mine so it's real you know